Did you ever wonder what fish do all day?
One way to find out is by going snorkeling.
All you need are a mask, fins and a short tube called a snorkel.
Then, just swim near the surface of the water and see what's happening under the sea!
I just love people watching!
A group of fish swimming together is called a school of fish.
I can't wait to see what we learn today on Fishy's Wiki!
Did you know scuba divers can go even deeper than snorkelers underwater?
Scuba stands for Self-Contained Underwater Breathing Apparatus.
Scuba divers wear special equipment to help them move, breathe and see underwater.
Ooh, I look good!
You can scuba for all sorts of fun reasons like just to see beautiful things, science.
It's fascinating! I don't think anyone has cleaned this floor in years!
Searching caves, photography,...
Perfect!
...and even making movies!
To be or not to.
Dory, let's do that again!
But this time, remember your lines!
One of the best places in the world to go for an underwater adventure...
...is the Great Barrier Reef off the coast of Australia.